i really want to apologize and again
stress
that i really want
all the best for you i should have been
a better person i should have
it's been a long time coming but darcy
finally gets an apology from her exes
tom and jessie for the way they've
treated her during an intense part two
of the darcy and stacy tell-all that
aired monday on tlc
all of it needed to come out everything
needed to be discussed and talked about
but before tom and jesse decided to make
peace the drama was piping hot he needs
to cool off jesse's appearance on the
tell-all didn't sit well with darcy's
brother-in-law florian who questioned
why jesse was even there he's just
popping up like a weasel everywhere i
don't know how he popped right he's
popped up are you talking for my
sister-in-law are you talking for my
sister-in-law i'm a man calm down bro
are you talking from my sister on tv
screen i'm talking to you ah are you
talking for my sister-in-law drink your
full coffee water what you have steve
bro i'm drinking some hot tea
and i'm spilling the tea hey this dude's
getting off of this bro relax this
dude's getting off on this bro chill man
jessie also rubbed darcy's close friend
michael the wrong way leading them both
to walk offset he's a loser that dude is
a loser bro during the confrontation
darcy had to once again deny jessie's
claims that she cheated on him with tom
we were pretty much done tom was my
friend at the time and i had known tom
for years prior
it's something tom denies as well like
for me the definition of cheating is if
you were still going balls deep in her
and you weren't so
tom also revealed that darcy's now
ex-fiance georgie once reached out to
him like georgie did with jesse but
unlike jesse he chose not to get
involved because it wasn't his business
i just think once you've moved on with a
relationship and if you're in a happy
place with a new partner then
really to go and speak with an ex it's
not my place to sit and talk to an
ex-partner i'm not here to throw darcy
under a bus and talk about all the stuff
she did or didn't do you keep coming
back like a bad smell
oh
jesse went on to defend himself and said
he was coming from a place of love and
wished darcy the best he then called tom
a hypocrite
you're coming here being a hypocrite and
i will not take it instead tom reached
out to him about darcy at one point
later on in the show darcy got emotional
after host sean robinson asked her about
the negative comments jessie and tom
have both said about her
darcy admitted that jessie had hurt her
more it's it's hurtful like you know
it's like
jabs and jokes yeah yeah so it feels
bullyish
but i'm not with the jabs in the gym
that's all i mean yeah i got kids i'm a
mom and i just don't want that to hurt
them
yeah they see these comments too darcy's
vulnerability led tom to take full
responsibility for his actions there's a
main doors who were friends
and i knew what jesse had done to her
and i should have been better jesse
didn't know better i did i should have
been a better person i should have
then surprisingly in comes jessie with
an apology
i feel
really bad if she is hurt the way that
she expresses and i really want to
apologize and again stress
that i really want
all the best for you
and that's
i i mean it with all my heart that is
sincere darcy thanked jesse and accepted
both of their apologies
i really hope that those words are
really sincere and truthful and uh only
wish you guys the best that's all i want
everybody to be happy
et recently spoke with darcy and she
revealed why she and georgie who was a
no-show at the tell-all have broken off
their engagement for the second time and
it was a decision
uh that i made personally for myself for
my daughters and i took a stand because
i felt like the relationship wasn't
moving in the right direction from that
point of being engaged which happened in
the summer mind you you know the towel
was in winter time so there had been
some time and communication still wasn't
going well there was a lot of things
that just
weren't
where they should have been and i take
accountability where i do but i just
felt like for me i needed to just walk
away and once it left
my mind my body followed and
i just i hit my limit with him
you